hello everyone and welcome back to the
video World rapid Championship 2022 with
what could be the game of the uh fide
World rapid Championship it is Daniel
dubov or rather Anish giri with the
white pieces against Daniel dubov and
this game is an absolute Masterpiece I I
I I definitely I haven't seen all the
games but this does feel like it could
be the game of the championship let's
dive straight into it and see uh what
happened here if you haven't seen uh
dubov's game against nikal sarin do
check that out as well as it's a really
awesome one so let's check it out Anish
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for directi we have
Pawn to D5 and now G3 going for the
king's Indian attack G6 Bishop to G2
both players Finch on their Bishops D4
and Knight to F6 and here we have C4 and
we transpose into the Neo groomfield
defense uh we have C6 by adub of end
here Anish trades once characters
captures and Knight the C3 now both now
uh Dube of castles we have Knight E5 by
Anish always an excellent Square for the
Knight and the the position is a fairly
standard one here you will often see an
E6 mover night the E6 move but do both
goes for what could only be described as
a true dubovian move and that is Knight
to E4 so it's a straight out Pawn
sacrifice there is no other way to
uh to explain this and the question is
always the same what does a black game
by sacrificing this pawn and okay Anish
accepts of course Knight captures and E4
he knows from theory that this can't be
good so the best way to refute it is to
buy accepted the characters and now
there is a game where castles was played
by Anish boldly captures the pawn with
bishop captress and E4 and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so what uh how can dubov continue
this well he offers another Pawn Knight
the C6 it's not so much offering a pawn
because if you go for the pawn then your
D4 Pawn will become weak he has a very
different idea Knight captures on C6 B
captures and now uh like I said if you
go for the pawn uh then uh well okay
Rook to B8 is always strong the D4 Pawn
will be hanging so maybe it's too too
ambitious of a pawn grab Sonic goes
Bishop to E3 he just defends his D4 Pawn
but now Bishop to H3 for the price of
that one Pawn dubo gets the keep
anisha's King in the center of the board
but only momentarily because Ponte F2 he
will Castle artificially with King to F2
and then bring the Rook into the game
and dubov now goes Rook to B8 now puts
pressure on the beat you upon Anish
defends it and now rooked the B for
adding more pressure to that Central D4
pawn and Anish plays King to F2 uh you
you should also consider something like
Queen to D2 you put pressure on the rook
and then as dubov defends it you can
play even Rook to C1 now put pressure on
the C6 Pawn but anik goes for the
instant artificial castling King F2 and
now do both strikes with Pawn to F5 and
now uh how do you play this it doesn't
matter where the bishop goes uh dubov's
next move will be the same so Anish
decides to grab a pawn while he's added
the bishop captures on D5 and now look
at this point F4 completely shattering
anisha's King side now if you capture
with the bishop that's not really good
Bishop captures and D4 check will
connect with the Rook so Anish plays G
captures on F4 and now look at this
point the E5 sacrificing more pawns and
okay nothing better than the captors and
E5 Anish has to accept this and this
does give him a past E Pawn but now
Queen to H4 with check King to G1 and
now how do you continue the attack all
of the squares are covered here so you
don't have any way of continuing uh
checks towards the white king uh Rook B
captures an F4 brilliant stuff by Dube
of this frees up the G5 Square for the
black Keen King at the price of the
exchange so Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Anish plays Queen to D5
with check up until this point Anish was
defending spectacularly and here he he
has to find Queen to C1 if he's to
continue defending because uh it guards
the G5 square but also the uh the C5
Square to give you an example now if
Queen captures an E5 you can just play
King to F2 and everything is is fine
white is now defending you don't have
any any checks you don't have Queen to
C5 check winning the bishop so that's
why Queen to C1 is such a strong move
but Anish spent a lot of time uh trying
to defend the position right from the
start right from that the bovian move
and he went Queen to D5 check but now
after King to h8 it proves uh that it is
just too difficult to defend this uh he
plays Queen to E4 but now he does not
control the G5 Square so Queen G5 check
King F2 and now Rook the F4 kicks away
the White Queen Queen to D5 and now
Queen to H4 with check and now the
problem is if you go King to G1 look at
this bishop to H6 and white resigns
there is nothing you can do here
uh the the main thread is if white let's
say pushes his pass Pawn wants to
deliver some checks or something uh Rook
Rook to G for check and now after Pawn
captures Bishop to E3 a spectacular
double bishop checkmate so instead after
Queen to H4 Anish is forced to seek
shelter elsewhere he plays King to E3
now Rook back to f8 uh guarding the back
rank but also freeing up the F4 Square
for his Queen we have Queen to C5 Queen
to D4 would be a bit more precise but
Anish goes for Queen to C5 and now Queen
to F4 with check King F2 Queen to H for
Chuck dubov repeats once but now finds
Queen to G5 with check and now if you go
back King to F2 look at this queen G2
checking E3 Bishop H6 check King to D3
and now a simple Bishop to F5 check and
that's it once you play something even
if you just go here let's say captures
uh no even Rook 38 with the check and
that's it you don't have um any squares
left you have to go to the C file and
once you go to the C file you just part
with your queen so that's why after
Queen G5 check Anish started running
with his King King D3 but now Rook the
d8 with check the king Hunt is uh well
already happening King to C4 Bishop to
E6 with check with King if you go King
to C3 is just a brutal Queen to D2
Checkmate so after Bishop to E6 King the
B5 was played look at the journey this
white king uh undertook I mean first F3
then Anish to write castling
artificially with King F2 and then the
king ends up on the queen side uh in in
the opponent's half of the board
absolutely brilliant now Bishop to F5
forcing the queen away from the defense
of the E5 Pawn so Anish still tries to
defend but now Rook the B8 with check
with King the A4 and now the spectacular
Queen to E7 threatening mate in one with
Queen to A3 so Anish plays A3 defends
the A3 square and now just the bishop
captures and B3 with check and there are
no more moves if you go up the board
then it's just a nice meeting too King
A6 Queen to B6 Checkmate so Anish has to
give up the queen he plays Queen
captures on B3 Rook captures King
captures and okay he does have two Rooks
for the queen but it's a matter of a
simple Queen to E6 check as it connects
with the bishop and he was in this
position on move 36 that Anish giri
resigned to the game and we have yet
another spectacular spectacular
Masterpiece by by uh well uh what can
only be described as a tall reborn
um uh Masterpiece so truly truly a
remarkable game uh and Anish defended
pretty much spectacularly up until the
point where he missed that uh crucial
Queen to C1 the defensive idea where it
guards the the G5 and C5 squares but in
anisha's defense uh pretty much every
every move do both played from like uh
after after he went for this uh silly
looking knight the E4 was was the the
top engine recommendation so he played
like like tal but like like an engine
tile so of you cannot play against that
and here uh when dubo feels inspired
he's just gonna Crush you it doesn't
matter if he has the white pieces the
black pieces he will just Crush you and
uh as dubov uh was uh in second place
before before playing this game he is
now very very close to catching up the
Magnus he already played Magnus so he
will have to look for his chances
elsewhere but I mean what what a game uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh if you if you ever play a
game like this uh you you will be happy
for the rest of your life but dubov has
this uh well this luck that he's able to
always play games like like these uh so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jeff
Graves David Rock rice Oxley Kevin Clark
Chris Malin and Rapid boss for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
defeated rapid world championship and
hoping for more games like this uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day